a lot of people fail because they talk
about [__] they think money will be in
look some people struggle with the
camera that's okay like maybe you can
write or maybe you can audio but if
you're gonna go in front of the camera
talk about what you know but you don't
need to be an expert you're the expert
of your life experiences you can talk
about anything I'd highly recommend
talking about stuff that you're
interested in because it becomes
sustainable a lot of people fail because
they talk about [__] they think money
will be in the amount of people that
I've physically watched in the last four
years go from Cannabis experts to nft
experts to real estate experts now
they're [__] AI experts I mean like
[__] yeah [__]
the only thing they're experts at is
suck it
when you put an expert in your name it's
almost immediately an indicator that you
want other people's money